the day before I release my album the
night before I was in the shower and I
just had this like breakdown it's like I
can't I can't release this album like no
no we have to call Roger and then it was
like we just we have to stop like push
the red button I can't there's another
thing that I could do there's no song
there's no I just no and so then I was
like that was just nerves but the 20
year old had nothing to worry about she
just made history with her self-titled
solo album she's the first woman in
three years to have her debut album bow
at number one on the Billboard 200 how
will you celebrate and who will you
celebrate with I'm gonna celebrate with
my family with my and with my team and
we're just gonna get crunk when I'm 21
we're gonna celebrate
on March 3rd yes you know celebrate wake
yeah yeah cuz I'm fully aware of how
hard it is to have a number one in your
career that's right and it's been so
close a couple times yeah but you just
can't be like happy number two yeah it's
like it's great but then it's kind of
like once you just get to number two you
just just really want to know so close
I heard that you went in with this album
and when in and reworked a few things
there was just things that I was
heartbroken about in the beginning that
four months or five months after I was
just I had totally moved on from it yeah
and I just felt like my music needed to
move on with me otherwise it was like I
couldn't imagine just facing everything
and having such a important big moment
in my life and giving that power to
something that hurt me it's like that's
not fair to me and what point did you
decide that I think it was a it was like
two weeks after I did promo with the
other album title yes because it was
like in every interview it's like oh so
what's that about and what's this and
and how did you feel and and I was just
kind of like this is new to god yeah and
I'm not even sad anymore yes you know
what I mean yeah I feel like me naming
it just my name just gave me back that
just that ownership of that this moment
and just like the power back in my life
[Music]
you've got guys like Keith Urban perform
your song on stage odd yeah Eliot John
saying quote you make me happy you make
me want to dance what did that feel like
when you that's the most romantic thing
the guys ever said to me I know you make
me happy you make me want to dance and
Elton John we're in love I'm just
kidding
Wow no it's it's amazing and I I felt so
I felt like I just could have responded
better because I was so excited when I
found out that I just took to Twitter
and I was like oh my god Elton John
knows my name
oh my god oh my god that's all I said
was just oh my god because I was just
freaking out and sometimes you're
speechless you don't know what to say
and you've also I heard just purchased a
house in Miami yeah how did that what
did that feel like oh it was amazing I
mean the fact that I get to do that
because it's basically it's me and my
whole family lives there I've never had
like a pool in Miami before so it's like
really nice because I would have to use
the community pool and people would like
recognize me and they would just like
start singing to me and I would just be
like I'm just gonna swim just go it
wouldn't happen yeah no yeah it's just
it's really really amazing I think that
was my favorite moment of of last year I
think my family's too